I'm Nick Montfort professor of digital
media in comparative Media Studies and
writing I also teach at the struggle for
poetic computation in New York I study
creative computing and develop
compositional art and poetry my computer
generated poetry books included shebang
the true list which is the first in
recent using electricity series from
counter path and hard West turn my
digital projects including the deletion
esteems far between and the translation
project renderings these are all
collaborations are available Nick and
calm and I have MIT press books some
collaborative some individually authored
which are the new media reader Christi
little passages racing the bean can can
print char string to a five-point fly
plus rant one go to ten that's the
reason why I have to introduce myself by
the way and exploratory programming for
the Arts and Humanities and most
recently the future so next introduce
Stefan helm right who's on the opposite
side of the table
who's the elting Morison professor of
anthropology he received his PhD in
anthropology from Stanford his research
is focused on how biologists think
through the limits of life as a category
of analysis which he's taken up in three
books alien ocean anthropological
voyages in microbial seas silicon
second-nature culturing artificial life
in a digital world and most recently
sounding the limits of life essays in
the Anthropology of biology and beyond
well on sabbatical this semester
Stefan holds fellowships from the John
Simon Guggenheim Foundation and at the
Radcliffe Institute for Advanced Studies
where is completing a manuscript that
offers an ethnographic account of how
scientists measure model and monitor
waves of climate change even though he
is on sabbatical with these two very
very desirable fellowships
he's kind enough to join us for the
panel so an extra measure of thanks is
the bond for being with us today
next to me Adam Horowitz is a master
student in the fluid interfaces group at
the Media Lab his work aims to augment
human awareness translating advances in
neuroscience into the design of
interventions and interactive
experiences across the Arts and Sciences
it works on how technology can show us
parts of ourselves that remain otherwise
invisible allowing for introspection
wellness and wonder he has background as
a neuroscience Tech MIT McGovern
Institute studying mindfulness
meditation and my watering and as an
artist scientist at the marina abramovic
Institute together tying together
neuroscience and performance art his
work has been shown at the Khan Film
Festival transmedia
stopped by Southwest the Beijing media
but you know SC SC pompeya
and the Boston Museum of Fine Arts here
at MIT he leads the skunk works team of
mighty hacking arts his current projects
include the microscopic virtual reality
adventures inside the human body along
with the dream control and capture in
the liminal space between Caroline a
Jones or end of the table studies modern
and contemporary art the particular
focus from its technological modes of
production distribution and reception
she is professor of art history in HTC
at the street hearing of criticism of
architecture and art programming
she was trained in visual studies in art
history at Harvard doing graduate work
at the Institute of Fine Arts in New
York before completing her PhD at
Stanford University previous to this she
worked in museum administration an
exhibit curation pulling physicians at
the Museum of Modern Art in New York and
the heart the Harvard University art
museums or she also completed two
documentary films beyond her work at
those institutions her exhibitions and
films have been shown at the San
Francisco Zoo in modern art Hirshhorn
Museum and sculpture garden in
Washington see the harmonies in the
tokyo boston university art gallery and
in my case list Visual Arts Center among
other venues caroline has written an
edited number books most recently the
global work of art which focuses on her
ongoing research interest including the
globalism the agency of the artist and
new media art and finally Agnieska
Courant is an interdisciplinary
conceptual artist who examines how
complex social economic and cultural
systems can operate in ways that confuse
distinctions between fiction and reality
or nature and culture her work
investigates the economy of the
invisible in which immaterial and
imaginary entities fictions phantoms
energy flows and emergent processes
influence political economic and
ecological systems
she often collaborates with scientists
including biologists anthropologists
photographers economists computer
engineers and roboticists many of her
works emulate nature and behave like
living organisms self-organized complex
systems or bachelor machines in 2015 she
did a commission for the facade of the
Solomon R Guggenheim Museum in New York
2013 to 2014 she presented a major solo
exhibition at the sculpture Center there
in there in New York in 2010 she Co
represented Poland at the venice
bienalle of architecture most recent
exhibitions include commissions for the
Guggenheim Bilbao SF MoMA Cleveland
triennial and as well as solo shows at
SCA emo MoMA and the CCA in Tel Aviv for
works also been exhibited at Palais de
Tokyo the Tate Modern in the kitchen
victory fries projects Madonna Musa
and bone occurrence burned student there
Hagen Performa be any older Agnieska is
currently the EDA Reuben
artist-in-residence at MIT is cast and
old fellowships at the Smithsonian
Institute and the American Institute
well as you can guess we have a group
with some relevant expertise in
perspective but also a diverse group and
I'd say that the four of you certainly
from different perspectives you
undertake types of inquiry exploring
asking questions generating new sorts of
insights this is something I think
unites people at the University of
generally even if they're doing very
different sorts of activities there's
some how when they're taking inquiry so
since our occasion here is discussing
I'm the eskas work at MIT as an artist
I'd like to ask how she inquires through
art and then invite the others of you to
explain how artistic inquiry is similar
to or different from the types of
thank you thank you so much thank you
everyone joining me I like the point of
departure of my work is I'm the
phenomenon that nature of the culture
that are examples of emergence and
collective intelligence
these phenomena have been in various
complex systems complex systems can be a
termite colony a human society human
brain the internet the urban fabric or
even the stock exchange there are
systems with many components and factors
that are so complicated that are often
very difficult to anticipate what kind
of happen in them they evolve in a
nonlinear way and I've been
investigating these systems I want to
show very quickly a couple of slides of
my points of departure of a couple of my
works I'm going to just comment it was
like one Center for image said this is
an organism that inspired a lot of my
works slime mold it doesn't have any
nerve nervous system but consists of
singular cells that when confronted with
some form of danger like of nutrients or
water and aggregates in well in a super
organism into one unit and moves as one
unit and displays signs of intelligence
so it can even go through a maze and in
fact it was co-opted for computation by
scientists such as Andrew yoga mats keep
working in a great britain who is doing
surgery who's running the center for
unconventional computing using
assignment and other organisms to
perform various operations this is
another example of emergence of
collective intelligence and culture of
bacterial colonies that
perform group sake and the work of a
Shelburne Jacob an Israeli scientist who
discovered that certain bacteria for
example make a collective decisions
where they let they decide to kill off
half of the colony for the collective
good future good of the remaining
bacteria and so it's kind of like a
infective visualization of a group
saying one welcome consider this is a
social phenomenon that happened on the
platform called reddit about a year ago
and about 1 million people participated
in it it was a sort of virtual fictional
country universe called the place or
each participant could place a single
pixel wherever they wanted in this
virtual space and various emergent self
organized processes emerged so a lot of
fictional characters fictional Nations
counts this is an example of one of them
and this is the black void another
blanket departure for a lot of my
research is at this branch of science
that that analyzes and gross artificial
societies and it started in the early
90s closely at the Santa Fe Institute by
two scientists Epstein and Axel that
some of this earlier research has been
done by the economist Thomas Schelling
it's basically a way of using algorithms
to calculate very complex systems of how
societies will behave the interplay
between individual decisions of citizens
in a society so here are some examples
of one of my words using the this
artificial society models based on the
Tomas sherek the The Economist his model
of self segregation
how it can actually be computed these
are the works that standing from all
this research
thank you these are the works this is a
series called aai which are works that I
outsource crowdsource to non-human
agents because I'm interested in also
forms of non-human intelligence in the
times when a lot of scientists are
talking about the fact that the
intelligence is not what the mostly
Western culture assumed to be individual
and located in the brain but on the
contrary its distributed and it's very
external to the brain and it doesn't
have to be human so a lot of my work are
also taking this as a kind of departure
and so these works were outsourced to
the colonies of living termites each
each sculpture is build by a colony of
approximately a million termites that
were supplied was alternative materials
such as pigmented sands particles of
gold and crystals and each colony is
isolated for about 3-4 months and they
just built and each form is different
nothing can be anticipated and there are
these hybrid forms that however between
nature and culture and what is really
interesting that the entomologist point
out how each single colony of exactly
the same species produces very different
shapes of termite mounds which also
corresponds to a different collective
personality of each colony so they just
like humans they can represent different
collective personalities or just like
social movements that sometimes can be
dynamic and fast sometimes more slow
dispersed or concentrator and headless
or not so this is an these works also
kind of related to my interest in soft
exploitations present society especially
by corporations using algorithms to
harvest data of
completely unaware of this so this is
like a distributed throttle of
exploitation that's a continuation of
this work where I am pouring how think
into abandoned start right miles and
they form this negative casts of various
so they are like internal portraits of
various societies they are put in an
African desert and this these works
entitled the end of signature that I've
done various iterations of I related to
my reflections about how the aggregated
value of social capital can not only be
exploited which is unfortunately
happening so often in contemporary
societies but it can also be precisely
calculated and can be used or analyzed
for a good cause and and then we should
maybe try to embrace it so so what I'm
doing in this work is of I I developed
together with computer programmers and
algorithm that morphs thousands of
signatures that we first collect and
scan into a collective signature and
I've developed this collective
signatures for various social movements
communities and and groups the first one
was a facade of the Guggenheim Museum in
New York and this is a collective
portrait of all the visitors kind of
alluding to the fact that viewership
today also became a form of labor a
visible labor because audiences are
constantly instagramming images and
circulating images and it became a sort
of form of invisible labor and
contributing to the value of the
artworks this is on the Cleveland Museum
of Art where this is all the employees
of this museum who donated their
signatures in this community this is a
community of people that make an one
building a new tract where which is like
a last final Island of public housing in
the middle of like a privatized public
space in the central Utrecht
this is a this is a project that also
uses like aggregation of human behavior
but in this case to produce like a
certain model of a collective Tamagotchi
or an organism or an animatronic soccer
ball in this case the piece of the title
was I object making a reference to
Michel Sarah's idea of like how certain
objects need to be activated as they're
circulated between agents so different
movements of soccer balls from games
played online by various users internet
users for and it's moving actually it's
a animatronic piece and finally the
series of works that that I realized
here at at MIT they started was a
serious called production line where I
started outsourcing my works to human
agents multiplicity of human agents
working on this new platform that in my
opinion is the beginning of the new
working class the platform is called
Amazon Mechanical Turk but there are
various similar platforms that exist and
they allow for crowd-sourced
labor people working on small tasks in
front of their computer screens online
around the world and this platform can
often although not always become
exploitative and but could also be
possibly in the future are used for the
public good because it allows for
collective intelligence experiments and
it has been used for some social
experiments so I took advantage of this
platform to crowdsource some of the
works to thousands of people also
working worldwide and this series is
called production line where each worker
was asked to draw a single line and then
they were
fused into this collective drawings that
were then output it as you can see was a
pant water as a one single line
continuous line and then so each drawing
and up represent an amalgamated labor of
in this case five hundred one thousand
or two thousand people that each line
has been drawn in a different part of
the world and what is most important
about about this works is that I created
a system that allows for profit sharing
so it in a way it allows for siphoning
of the money from the art market and
redistributing and among these workers
so they are participating in the profits
and when each of these works sells they
are but they are being hired on the spot
as they complete their work but
additionally if the work sells the the
proceeds are evenly distributed amount
of the participants because Amazon
Mechanical Turk platform allows for
storing their IP addresses so we can pay
them bonuses at any point in the future
of the work cells this is a project that
I developed here already at MIT was a
generous collaboration from the sea sale
of a team by Professor Lawrence Katz who
is present here and also my rebirth
booth and this work entitled assembly
line and continues the idea of how how
to subvert the systems of Microsoft
exploitation so in this case we we
worked on the ways in which how people
donate their volunteer during their data
their bio data online we transformed it
to the ways in which people taking
selfies or any kind of self-portraits
how big would be aggregated into a
collective self-portrait of this
collective worker that this new working
class constitutes so what you're looking
at is like an aggregate
of about 10,000 people and photograph
self-portraits of like 10,000 people and
then are aggregated into one and then I
on the basis of several images that we
generated at csail I created this 3d
forms that are these abstractions that
represent is collective self portrait of
this society and this this project is
now evolving further where workers from
the same platform are going to put
together abstract machines from
different machine parts and lastly I
would like to show just one of the
project that I did here at MIT and have
untitled animal internet and I
collaborated with Adam Horowitz was
present here as well as Atmos camera
anyway it's over here somewhere and when
True Blood and a shower and it's in many
ways like a culmination of all this
research between non-human intelligence
and collective intelligence and
artificial intelligence so what happens
here is dead inspired by the phenomenon
of animal internet where a lot of
scientists are tracking animals all over
the world and on the one hand by putting
chips and animals and that they can be
followed digitally but also by placing
cameras in jungles or in the North Pole
and watching completely wild animals
without their knowledge about this
phenomena I I realized that since these
animals have a kind of hybrid life
because many of them are followed on
this webcams they have web websites
Facebook pages and a following of
sometimes a couple of hundred thousand
people so it creates this kind of hybrid
reality between wilderness and and
culture so what we did together with
hugging arts team is we created this
project which consists of two real
webcams that are broadcasting real wild
and the most one is a tiger in the
jungle and one is a polar bear and the
North Pole and we here at MIT built too
artificial
animals so they're animatronic animals
we used artificial fur so no animals
were harmed and this is and and they are
basically one of them the one in the
upper right corner was powered by a
workers of the Amazon Mechanical Turk
that sent as their task which they were
paid and they sent information about how
they were feeling feeling whether they
were tired hungry angry or relaxed or
hand happy and this aggregated emotions
like through sentiment analysis and
different kind of programs that we use
and we converted into various behaviors
out of this fictional animal in a kind
of jungle arranged internal environment
and the other camera is a swarm of
gerbils which was like an assert
environment and this one is powered by
Twitter scraper that we wrote so
basically like we were monitoring
Twitter account of all the protest
movements in the world
and what kind of sentiments they are
expressing whether it's frustration
hope aggression whether it's a positive
and negative end and and so this
aggregated data from different social
movements were then powering a sugar
scape model an artificial society model
that was translated
the behavior of this Swami thank you
thanks very much I want it so first of
all I wanted to know because there's
five chairs I can see please please come
in you don't even have to sit in the
front row please please come and occupy
them and thanks very much I guess Kapur
so you you showed some images of your
work you told us about your process and
your interest I wanted to ask one more
thing I wanted to get you to say
something about how you work as an
artist to do inquiry specifically
because I've asked togethers to respond
to this topic like how the way in which
they acquire is different then more
similar to artistic angry so can you
tell us I mean I was hoping that kind of
that's my answer but of course well you
know I mean I I cooperate was very
scientist but I'm trying for my work not
to be illustrative so it's always
somehow twisted and I really like
crossovers between different things that
maybe wouldn't cross over in real life
and to establish connections or
dialogues between sometimes scientists
that maybe wouldn't normally meet and
wouldn't necessarily in a time work and
even if it leads to miscommunications or
errors but this errors could be
productive so so it's never you know
although it is a cooperation with with
Sciences and other professionals there's
always a very strong component or like
our ISM as I call it and irrationality
and and slippage --is and just
unexpected nonlinear things well thanks
very much I think that's very
conservative and I think that that's
very consistent with with what you've
shown but you highlighted these two
aspects that your work is collaborative
it's not just the termites
it's lamebull but but you're working
collaboratively and you're also
interested in so we asked for perhaps
inquiry that's your question
yeah I'm an anthropologist and so my
mode of inquiry is ethnographic
fieldwork and I spend time with people
with collectives and try to figure out
what they're doing by doing participant
observation by interviewing them I spent
a lot of time with scientists in
particular and you know I bring us out
of tools to that inquiry which are
things that are that I've gathered from
the social theory toolkit which include
analytics of gender and race sexuality
ideas about belief ideas about
conviction hegemony practice ideology
this whole kind of toolkit of things and
the idea is to bring those with me into
the zone of inquiry hanging out with
people and see what they do and and
sometimes they can explain things and
sometimes they break and they can't
explain things or people give me other
categories and say well no no this is
not really about whatever you say it's
about really it's about complexity or
really it's about non-linearity since I
spend a lot of time studying scientists
I get a lot of that and say no no you're
you're saying that this is to do with
culture and power but really it's a
scaling problem that's about a certain
kind of sort of nonlinear dynamics that
properly understood as emergent
phenomena would reveal x y&z you know
and then I can speak back to that and
say well yes no so I think part of what
I have in common with agneta then is
that encounter with the unexpected right
this empirical work and then the attempt
to sort of to to find something and
encounter something that is surprising
within that but then also to sometimes
you know be assertive about my own
categories and say this is patriarchy
what is going on with this Cavanaugh
thing at the moment that is patriarchy I
am not buying it
sorry anyway this is daughter's prayer
daughter's prayer I think so I was
originally signed up to be our
respondent yeah I I think that it it's
not immediately apparent I am at an
earlier stage of question and asking
then fellow panelist so I will try to
contribute productive confusion or
because I am productively confused
perhaps my background at the moment is a
mix of neuroscience and art and I wanted
to touch quickly on why I think that's a
worthwhile mix and why is a contribution
in this conversation
um I think neuroscience stands out
especially stands out an institute like
this because it is such a unstable
meeting ground of objectivity and
subjectivity
it is a attempt at a third-person study
of first-person experience with
first-person experience it is so
contingent and murky um it makes it
really exciting to study it also means
that you don't get to stand on two
stable feet in either the realm of the
study of experience or the creation of
experience so um my interest and
exciting about against his work and and
modes of inquiry were similar in that
there's a mix of stability and
instability there's a clear picture that
comes out of a very murky collection of
parts I'd say that something that's
really nice in terms of the collective
piece that that this sort of subjective
objective mixes
has affected upon me is a sense of
myself as collective I studied here a
few years ago in the neuroscience
department largely neural networks and
which changed my notion of self as a
notion of there's a me in a little bit
of jelly I gotta get it and I'll get the
jelly eventually to something more like
I am temporal dynamics
I am rhythm I am time I am waves so the
the movement from functional
neuroanatomy as a sort of phrenology to
one of instead dynamic networks myself
as collective and then I take it even
further to if you if you do something
like a komissarov I'm a patient and the
neuroscience is somebody who's had their
hemispheres but something that has stuck
with me as a personal collective is you
might think that when you cut someone's
brain in half it started turns off and
it doesn't people keep functioning quite
well but some develop alien hand
syndrome which people might have heard
of but you you you develop essentially
hands that disagree so one might want to
button up one might want to button down
you develop hands that have different
information streams to the world um one
is more verbal one we have more sensory
motor information um and it's
interesting that you can break in that
way but it's also interesting um that if
you were currently broken in that way
broken in terms of being a collective
even you wouldn't know the notion that
introspection as an attentional
spotlight is a unifier of many cells
that I might have at the moment I should
invoke that but I might have at the
moment a more verbal a younger and older
Portuguese speaking in English speaking
a mix of selves with a mix of knowledge
--is and that my attentional spotlight
is one of those and so what I see inside
is a necessary unification of a possible
split collective if that makes sense has
stuck with me in a big way and that's
exciting I at the moment mostly study
sleep which is also a weird way in which
people break very predictably
if you get people at the right state of
sleep they will lose syntax they will
pull memories from different parts of
their lives that they wouldn't pull when
they were awake they'll be more fluid
thinking the way more rigid thinking I
work specifically in a weird sleep state
called hypnagogia and in that sleep
state you have a really like deep in
version of an organizing principle to a
collective intelligence which is that
when you're awake as a as a machine
you're generally I I think designed to
associate to things that are close
together and make predictions about the
world accordingly um there is a
Association my head between water bottle
water drinking thirst excetera I'll move
towards it when one concept comes up in
hypnagogia you get a full inversion um
it becomes much harder for people to
react to things that are closely
associated versus associated at long
distance so you have people have faster
reaction times when you associate a
porpoise and a helicopter than a
porpoise in the ocean and this is
exciting to me because it's like whoa
I'm a collective which I can't
introspect on but I can get down to base
and switch those base rules and see a
different collective in different states
um if that makes sense that the sleeping
self first is not sitting so so the
collective question touches on a lot of
things I'm excited about um personal
collectives extended and active
intelligence which we'll probably get
into later so I won't get into no
and then lastly excites me because um
the reason I'm here is that ignition
agnus and Asia and many of us and Gary
and we look got to collaborate on a
project in hacking arts and I think that
hacking arts is a sort of nice
demonstration of a certain organizing
principle of emergence where I'm not a
personal believer in the idea that you
can take a bunch of dumb parts and put
them together and get something
automatically intelligent without some
sort of organizing principle but I think
that hacking arts kind of turns out like
that you just throw a bunch of people
who are really different into a room and
they kind of bounce off each other and
things pretty predictably come out and
that's really been very exciting for me
as a sort of person who gets to guide
that and can
Gide that so I would yeah I would say
that packing words for me as a
collective is there's a there's that I
think it's a cut above line there's
about emergence oh no its Danny Hillis
it's like we
how can a bunch of stupid things come
together and be smart I'm really
interested in hacking arts which how can
a bunch of smart things come together
and be stupid in terms of producing
absurdity or getting past utility if
that dates hopefully that's what we
doing tonight all that to say I am
confused by my disciplinary past I think
it's a productive confusion that
contributes to the notion of being a
confused collective which is how I
introspect upon myself and also how I
try to work in the world which is what I
think happened arts does and I think the
project did I think that's why I'm here
[Applause]
well I'm actually very moved to respond
to Adam I mean this is not the gestalt
theory that I was taught by Rudolf are
not right so I'm really excited that
neuroscience is in a place where I can
think of that dynamic flow and sort of
collectivities that split and come back
together
I had Lydia bring in this video which
you can watch and if you get bored with
me or even if you don't eventually
around about 15 seconds in 20 seconds in
you'll see the slime mold social amoeba
form an aggregate and what's amazing
about this unicellular organism that
emerges into a multicellular organism is
that it does so while each cell
maintains its identity as it were I mean
it doesn't presumably have consciousness
as we hubristic imagined it but it's
organizing itself into this slug which
is then going to move off to the left as
an organized entity looking for food as
a collective that
chemically directs itself towards the
food that it might be able to sense in
its medium and what's cool about this
scientific video is that at the very end
of this loop you'll see this slug become
a vertical fruiting body okay so it
actually is coming up vertically from
the agar plate right here and standing
up and going like okay I give up there's
no food I'm going to make spores I'm
going to make spores and what's
hilarious about the science of this is
that it's attracting people that are
just incapable of thinking of this
without words like altruism and
selfishness and sacrifice and right so
if you don't get to be a spore you lose
buckwheat you know and the science about
this kind of material so I look to
culture as an art historian I look
historically to see what artists have
done with certain generative concepts
and in that sense I'm I'm very much fond
of Stefan's toolkit and we've
collaborated on some things together
with great pleasure so I look
historically at what they've left us
traces you know texts images journals
interviews and then as a critic in the
contemporary world I work with
contemporary artists whose work excites
me very much and seems to propel as Nog
rafi the future if you will and
something coming into being a kind of
emergent thinking that I want to be part
of her I want to see in the world
so I guess because presentation was
wonderful her her article in cabinet is
very interesting about the have to read
the title the uncomputable but we're
Slon mold in her thinking is a kind of
model for a certain calculational
possibility I'm actually looking for
something else in slime mold so the
artists working with biological material
that have taught me things that have
helped me think are ones that are
crafting when I've been calling bio
fiction and they've been doing so for
okay here's the utopian project a
cultural evolution that I want to see
happen then I'm calling symbiotic so I
just use whatever platform I have to tap
this stupid picture so the idea of the
antic is that which is and the idea of
symbiosis is that's what we are we are
flan we are completely pathetically
dependent on our environment on our
planetary systems on the scrub life of
which we are a part and the sooner we
can get rid of the fantasy of the
selfish individual The Selfish Gene
whatever the selfish thing is sooner we
can get rid of that the better the
sooner we can think together to sense
somehow our complete dependence on the
planetary systems that make our
consciousness and our lives possible the
better right so art that does that is
art that at the moment I'm excited by
and want to celebrate because I have
another fantasy which I'm sure my
anthropologist friend could disabuse me
of that we make art to externalize
something that then changes us write
that then evolves us to a different kind
of creature right so this is my fantasy
and I celebrate that contemporary art as
a place that I don't know how to get to
but there seem to be quite getting there
they seem to be emerging into that
project of collective I don't want to
call it intelligence collective action
Collective sensing collective being in a
chemical bath which is under theorized
right the binary bits of neural nets
forget about the synapse which is a gap
that has to be bridged by wet chemicals
right so for me these cultural
conversations these metaphors we live by
are metaphors that will help us possibly
live in the future
and if we can't do it we deserve to be
extinct so I appreciate that concept
also actually I want to ask
among the many topics we have related to
neuroscience and biology artistic
connection to science I wanted to talk
about one related to culture and power
specifically that a lot of the
formulations of collectivity that we
that we look to things like Amazon
Mechanical Turk are pretty higher even
something like Wikipedia well life isn't
modeled in the same way with payment
structure there are definitely higher
fees petrol is at the very least of
power authority expertise many ways
miraculous project are there examples of
human collective intelligence that think
of where people aren't exerting power
over each other where there is a more
genuine form of collectivity or are
there ways in which we're moving toward
that and this may relate I can ask it to
you know your work in providing proceeds
from art sales to the participants
but how is it that we make a move toward
not hire folks I think it's an
interesting question and one of the
reasons why I was fascinated by this
research and through artificial
societies is because this was the first
time I believe that that modeling for a
complex behavior of societies allowed us
to understand that any system of this
complexity naturally goes into a
physical embryo so even if you give
people equal chances on the start it
will unless it's monitored constantly
and and the simple the simple in my
opinion the simple and short answer to
your question is no there are no systems
like this because immediately unless
it's heavily monitored and and
supervised which could probably which
could entail other problems such as
surveillance and it's every system is
going to naturally push into some kind
of disequilibrium and and this
proportion and that relationship power
and I'm obviously exploring and that's
why I'm looking for like various weird
phenomena that emerge out of the blue
that are really like bottom-up emergent
processes that sometimes look strange we
don't really know what to make of them
what is their purpose some of them are
almost having structural artworks there
was apart from the experiment that I
shown and there was a this experiment
another experiment called take care of
my plant which I mean it's kind of
absurd it's like different people also a
dreaded platform different people were
asked to participate in like watering
this one plant so they were sending
comments through through a platform and
this plant was being nurtured by
thousands or hundreds
thousands of people what is what does
this mean what is the purpose of a
dislike so it wasn't even a social
experiment it was something some
emergent action and I think that you
know they're the only hope for me is
that looking at spontaneous emergent
phenomenon society of course including
social movements but even these very
often you know turned to become a
trickle or turn to be and there was
obviously this question of headless
revolution whether it's possible or not
how effective can it be or not and and I
you know that I think this is why the
it's very interesting to have this
debate was I was on to apologists
because like looking into very strange
social phenomena throughout the history
of human civilization maybe can provide
some examples but I am rather skeptical
could I make a comment on this because I
think the idea of our present models of
artificial intelligence as being somehow
exemplary is deeply flawed because each
of those are based on code that gets
handed on and passed on and it is
totally baked into hierarchies of when
it was built know there was even junk in
there that's like you know chat you know
so I'm informed by the work of like
Wendy Chung who's a great media theorist
who traced back the homophony algorithms
of Facebook right if you like this you
know in Amazon if you like this feel
like this right the so-called echo
chamber that we find ourselves in
socially to a pioneering study in the
1950s by an urban theorists right and
Nick probably knows all of this and
remembers the gods name anyway
it was two paradigms of which only one
was chosen for the future development of
all sorting algorithms the two paradigms
were birds of a feather lived together
soared together and the other urban
study of neighborhoods was opposites
attract these two bits of difference
liking and difference hating sort
completely differently and the one that
software developers chose was homophily
was birds of a feather
always
to flock together that's because when
redlining was happening you know
redlining was happening in their
neighborhoods they were already whites
who were benefiting from that privilege
you know what I'm saying so even though
the urban study guy wanted to look at
the non racist model that's not what got
baked into all of our systems so I as a
culturalist and a historian want to
insist that there's nothing neutral
about the intelligences as we now define
them and when I was privileged to be at
a session with Danny Hillis you know on
you know possible minds with a bunch of
robotics people who now have second
thoughts know what about AI it's kind of
scary actually anyway I said guys what
about the immune brand you know it
learns it teaches us it remembers things
it forgets things it's distributed it's
not exactly conscious maybe it is we
don't really know the point is it works
both to take in and to reject and the
fact that all we spend our money on this
antibiotics and the probiotics aren't
even regulated by our federal drug
authority tells us something about how
our route algorithms are organized right
so on I'm looking for different
metaphors to get going and I'm looking
to art for doing that so well if there's
more sounds
Harley's power gender yeah there's more
to say on this I I don't know if I'd add
something hopeful but I might add
something like rising that occur more
more more linking than no D in terms of
hierarchy setups I think that the the
sort of AI as scary take is is
interesting I think also that the way
that AI is changing us in the way that
we see technology is is sort of
different conversation which gets left
out sometimes in terms of how is it that
we're relating to those sorting
algorithms and how are they changing us
as information processors and Packers
and something I wanted to add which
might might be interesting to hire at
conversation is transactive memory as a
sort of linking concept meaning culture
as a form of collective memory that no
one person holds and the notion that I
as an individual in a culture don't need
to remember necessarily the history of
when this space was burned or built I
need to remember the person who
remembers the history and the notion
that that sort of linking is being
extended to such a great to agree with
current information sorting becoming so
effective where I I know not only do I
not need to know where the when the
house was built or burned III barely
need to remember the person who
remembers the name of the house and as
you get more effective linking in this
way I think you start to live more in
the links rather than in the notes of
information um so I think the
interesting thing about it in in my lab
we do some work on tech and memory and
there's really nice work showing that as
you for instance teach people about
Wikipedia pages they stop remembering
the content and they start remembering
how to find the content they move
towards the
link's I think that I see this in myself
and things like family history and
myself like working in a lab with
distributed kind of expertise right I
don't really feel like I need to know
much about circuits because there's a
person next door who knows a lot about
circuits um I'm really curious about the
kind of hierarchy that's turning me into
and what it means if I live more links
to information and less in terms of
nodes less in terms of expertise less in
terms of that sort of hierarchy and what
it means to start forgetting the things
and remember that remembering the paths
do the things forgetting the name of the
thing so well let me let me move on to
another question to which the answer may
also just be no but I'm wondering with
the because we're characterizing so many
things that's collected right we're
talking about this the self the minds
society of mind which is you know mad
for the exam metaphor - neural activity
and the brain in in terms of society
obviously there's the collective nature
of society and there's particular online
labor platforms there's collaboration
also
so I guess what I'm wondering is whether
it's useful to distinguish what is it
redundant to say collective intelligence
is there another kind of intelligence
does it is there a reason that we would
even say that to put an emphasis on
something
what are we distinguishing it from
discussing earlier about the distinction
between intelligence and creativity I
think these two questions are related
and I think that in principle in my
opinion it's a false binary because any
kind of creativity involves an
intelligence and vice versa and it was a
lot of this conversation about
creativity versus intelligence was
actually generated by neoliberal
discourse Richard Florida and and an
exploitation of his creative
intelligence for for purposes of
corporations for example and I think
that this whole binary is completely
false
but what for example is interesting for
me in terms of collective intelligence
and why I think that it's it's important
to distinguish it even if it's a play on
the husband maybe is the fact that
especially culture and especially
Western culture in particular has this
tradition of thinking about intelligence
as individual and and located in the
brain and at human and I really
appreciate what Karolina was was saying
I absolutely share your interest in this
real that this has to this
anthropomorphize ation of intelligence
and and the idea of like this individual
intelligence it has to stop because not
only obviously scientists are observing
since a long time that intelligence is
distributed then it's external to the
brain and it can be collective it can be
also known human and
and intelligence essentially as a lien I
would even say you know what in a way
and especially was the microbiome
research that is both inside of our our
bodies that also is external in a way so
it's both US and on us and I think that
that it actually brought the whole
conversation and coming back to things
we chattering about AI the whole
anthropomorphize ation of artificial
intelligence that it's it's it's a
single brain or it's a single entity or
a robot or something it's just like a
such a blind alley because there are
actually all this other forms of
intelligence that's and as much color as
possible neural networks which is used
by which are used by scientists that it
is a multiplicity it's a network it's
that so it's useful to ask who is served
by the fiction of the solitary unit and
you know the market is very well served
by this yeah so the I see i just opened
a beautiful show with jason moran and
their stated intention was to sort of
break with the art world's fixation on
the individual and talk about
collaboration but it's called
jason moran you know what i mean so they
they can't really get there because
they're inside they're inside the art
market but they know they want to get
there right so you just you can just see
the function of these ideologies as they
as they operate I mean so one one thing
he could come to with the term selective
intelligent perhaps also like
about the nature of intelligence by
adding by adding these terms we need to
adjust our welcome back to atoms point
there's also the binary we've dumped
right so we I mean we function with that
and you know I'm gonna I'm gonna Nick
didn't want to talk about this but like
MIT has a whole Center for collective
intelligence and what they're trying to
do over there at the Sloan School is
actually not be done not have algorithm
to determine our president for example
yeah you know and that is a very
important project even though it
operates within all the hierarchies with
all the biases that you know can
possibly cooked into all this at least
there are some humans that are trying to
you know move move the debate within
things that we have already unleashed
right that are already operating in
fairly stupid ways to run our social
lives
I just want to quickly I think that
Professor John said about about emergent
intelligence to emergent being I think
it's really interesting interesting
comment if smarter is what we're trying
to be when we group together or not
there's there's nice research out of MIT
well I think was Malone and then more
recently at Sandy Pentland I mean love
um doing work on what it is that
predicts effective collaboration and it
is um it's it's it's never it's never
picking an individual number to be
smarter than the rest of group and talk
more or even three within 10 it's always
a measure of social cohesion that's the
best predictor of output and I think
that that's research that that people
have come across and has been around for
a while there's more recent research
which i think is interesting in
in what president said about our our
country making collective decisions
which we question which is that that
that measure of social cohesion is no
longer a good measure of group output um
if those people are not in person if
they're communicating over text on the
internet then that that is no longer the
measure that predicts group intelligence
as it was measured in the original I'm
alone with I find that pretty scary in
terms of the ways that we're going to
relate that scale and so I really
appreciate the move from emergent and
telogen immersion being whether
intelligent is what we're aiming for and
whether intelligent is what we're
actually studying I think it's really
exciting that one hundred and Sun a flat
service walk in a circle and die and
five hundred thousand can see the world
I don't know if what they're doing is
being intelligent
I think it's cool to complicate so let
me ask because the topic has come up
about authorship one might say but also
being an artist as a singular you know
type of activity either promulgated I
mean copyright law coming about to be
able to make marketable and of course
has its own version of this also it's
not just in publishing right so it's
actually a case that this work arises
even if it's not done by explicitly by
collaborative even if it's not even if
it's not Shakespeare working out he's
playing with the troupe of actors you
know or someone with toriel supervision
and collaboration
it occurs in the social context it
occurs collectively in various ways and
I think we recognize that the standard
but then I guess the question is what's
going to happen with it well I think the
art world will be the last to go so I'm
fascinated by artists who have some
experience with say the theatrical arts
or the music world like Jason Moran
right there are very well elaborated
control systems of credit and sharing in
those worlds even down to jazz
improvisation you know where it's like
it's your turn the drummer you know the
second you get into the art world right
everything changes so an artist like
William Kentridge who loves opera who
wishes he could just do opera hmm needs
to go over here and make a dry and sell
it for $300,000 so he can make an opera
right because opera doesn't make money
opera is collaborative opera has many
many people working on it all of whom
get paid and are given credit right so
ironically the thing he can do himself
is paid more by the art world than the
thing that has to pay all those other
people now that that obscures the fact
that his workshop has a stable a very
committed people that he has worked with
almost in a theatrical troupe impresario
way for decades and and they don't their
name does not go
but let me ask so I understand from the
credit perspective the practices that we
can talk about it and we can share our
appreciation of it our understanding and
doesn't that come from knowing about
artists and their practices and if we if
we have something to eat we Agni ask his
work is interesting because we know
about her trajectory an artist and the
contextual of the contextual situation
of the other works that she's done and
her thinking and her perspective in the
way that she inquires I think her work
is unusual in the amount of credit that
she shares did discussion of her
collaborators I think that's unusual
and I think that's admirable but you
have to think we're not as interested in
her turkish stories as we are in her but
that could be a great hypnagogic
reversal instead of averaging those
emotions yes you know right drilling
down and and there is some you know
there is some effort to do that there's
some work with these effective
communities I think you know I'll just
throw out another example of collectives
which I would love to get onionskin
response to so in defin which is the
special economic zone of Shenzhen the
art village was collected by the part
party state in China and told that they
should each paint their dream on the on
this particular canvas but on the other
side they should paint an exact replica
of this thing over here this little chip
this little photographic chip and
they're very highly skilled at
replicating photographic information on
whatever they're given and when all of
the tiles were put together by the party
state
they made a giant Mona Lisa not from
their dreams which are now on the back
of the canvas their individual dreams
but the front which they were given as
actual living human Mechanical Turk now
composes the dolphin Mona Lisa which is
so much better than Leonardo's because
we
together right so this this trope of the
collective is also cultural conceit and
it bears with a tremendous power for the
political narrative right so the
hierarchy that determined which worker
we get which chip you know which piece
of the Mona Lisa is erased in the
discourse about this wonderful
collective right so you're you know you
can always do that interesting analysis
of the history and how it works with
these concepts the name of the
Mechanical Turk is an obscene
Orientalism right that we just use
without reflection but it already
encodes the hierarchy of this automata
without brain that will perform upon
demand I mean so you know can we reverse
that narrative in any way with that
platform I mean I think we'd have to
rename it sound so it does seem like
historic sizing these terms is one way
to break them right the history of the
collective and collective farming and
the former Soviet Union is a different
kind of a collective and the kind of
utopian thing that maybe we're talking
about a little bit here right and I
think a lot of discussions of collective
intelligence are and emergent
intelligence are haunted by a kind of
reductionist methodological
individualism right that somehow there's
this collective emanation of emergent
intelligence and then it's made of these
binary little bits crime and division
individuals which is kind of Western
liberal contract theory from Hobbes - so
to John Locke etc
monads that just sort of percolate right
with no with no mediating the middle
structure right I think that maybe
that's that's something we could think
about is what would be a mezzo theory
something that intervenes between the
kind of monads and this collective
effervescence well let's go there
because the monad is merely an
invagination or an extrusion from a
single divine body so I mean we could
get right there with the monad we could
we could get some fuzz and some
vagueness and some sliding going on it's
it's the bit that I think we we struggle
we struggle with exchange one is about
coming back again about to this question
of like creativity and and for different
projections and anthropomorphize ations
of oh my eye and it's useless and and
the something that is specific i think
about intelligence that is not machining
is a certain aspect of irrationality or
unpredictability or computability and
and i think that the problem that that
is now starting to be recognized by
scientists that it's this tendency to
act upon authorization but also of the
AI and and trying to think about how
this could be creative and how could we
first of all create and artificial
intelligence artists using algorithms i
think that one of the question is like
how do you actually imitate not the
intelligence but precisely the dominance
the stupidity or the things even more
broadly some kind of irrationality of
various kinds including stupidity Navy
tower or and this is becoming a
it's probably a good unprintable
challenge machines have their own type
of stupidity
it's called glitch yes but they're happy
imitate they don't have to imitate
agreed but you know there are different
kind of errors and glitches and of
course some artists are exploring the
schoolís machining glitches but actually
the kind of irrationality there's
something particular about it and and I
think that you know the the the
computability of like collective social
behavior which we can obviously and now
with all the algorithms that we haven't
had to for example we anticipate the the
election ourselves and other other
phenomena then become useless at the end
of the day because so many irrational
factors sometimes play into it I think
that you know I see I mean I kind of see
some hope in it because wouldn't it be
absolutely terrifying and everything
could just be computed and and we would
be able to anticipate everything like in
terms of any kind of creative excuse to
the word process of any kind not in
culture but in any I think actually this
would you know humans need not only this
sense of being able to control things
because obviously what is calculated the
ability to calculate things
it's obviously connected to our ability
to control things and do more to know
that we have done computable Zanda
rational factors this actually I mean
the dependent we still can have it thank
God is a positive thing but I don't know
for how long but I'm hoping that maybe
maybe always but and another point that
I wanted to make about the questions of
authorship and like where are where art
and culture could go I mean one of my
main areas of research is the research
is where its culture going to evolve
where it's going and I I think that
we're living in from any
reasons horrifying times but for other
reasons very interesting times because
we can witness as culture involves in
front of our times in front of our eyes
because it's some things are happening
so fast but one negative aspect of
evolution of culture is that it used to
be produced collectively and things like
the Bible or Dermatology's were
important products of culture was
multiple and on the most mostly
anonymous authors and even today like a
lot of people are indicating that even
constructs like Homer or maybe to
something or even Shakespeare actually
constitute a multiplicity of a certain
diversity of more than just one author
and at some point of culture of ocean we
arrived at a point where basically yes
as the Caroline pointed out cultural
industries or proton-proton industries
capitalized on the fact that if you have
a singular author it's going to be
easier to capitalize on it to market it
to to to and and we're yeah and we're
like at the point of concern of this
that that it's a total alienation almost
on the product and and I think that you
know creativity is a social relation
first and foremost and what happened in
culture is that creativity became a
relation between the product and the
author and I think and and this is why
you know precisely experimental support
pointing out that that you know the
objects that had were touched by the
artist had why is painting today as for
example like Isabella growl very
interestingly analyzes like why has
painting been so fetishized and and its
really reaching the highest prices is
because the the a lot of people who
understand culture in a kind of very
basic way they want to have the the
stigma of the artist the touch of the
artists hand even if it's metal
to some degree but still some kind of
expanded notion of fainting or an
expanding notion of sculpture something
that had a contact was the living body
of the artist and and it's obviously
just another you know like
commodification of a process that that
originally was you know general
intellect multitude of various various
people because it seems to me that there
it is possible it is you're mentioning
with regard to homework that we can have
works that don't have an author and that
are creative and influential socially
but we can't have something creative or
which will socially without some type of
cultural context worth to say that we
wouldn't say oh this is a very creative
meteorite that landed on the ground you
know I mean it's it's it has to be a
work that has some meaning situated
socially that's that's there I don't
know if it looked like I'm yes cos
sculpture my creative looking meteorite
yes that's work had certain orders that
we associate it but there was also
cultural materials but upon first
contact if it Rockets out of the sky and
lands in front of me and it looks like
her anodized metal baby this is an
empirical question we went to if we go
to
oh it's been done realizin already did
that but I'm making a different point
about where culture comes from so if it
Rockets out of the sky lands in front of
us and it looks like an es cos object
I'm gonna say there's probably some
culture in this right so I'm supplying
ya you know I'm part of the what I love
what Adam mentioned about this
collective project that defers memory
and stores it in other people and so on
and so forth
I mean maybe it would be a provocative
suggestion to say are we allowing
corporations to have collective
intelligence they're already affected
persons they're already victim bodies
you know what what are we you know we
have many many entities in our own
culture that are kind of allowed to
operate as if they possessed
intelligence and some of the AI crowd I
was hanging out with was saying that
this is already the singularity this is
already an artificial intelligence their
claim is that the CEO has to listen to
this aggregate that is this corporation
that the CEO is a fictive individual who
doesn't actually control what's going on
with this emergent property which is
called the capitalist corporation so I
take that pretty seriously there's a
history to that we decided to make them
people we decided to let them have free
speech we decided to let them you know
have certain ways of storing their
capital and moving it around that didn't
involve our our separate wishes so you
know some have argued that this is
already the singularity of a general
intelligence appearing in in our social
organizations
I think that's called a champion and I
think I do that on my interfaces I'm
also thinking back to the 19th century
and Charles Babbage its notion of
intelligence as not only a kind of
capacity or faculty but also has
knowledge about the conduct of
calculation and Charles Babbage not only
being famous for thinking about the
early theory and computation but also
somebody who is very interested in
factory manufacture and an organized a
shop floor and making the claim that
having the knowledge about how to
organize the shop floor meant having
intelligence and the intelligence
resided not in the craftspeople or in
the factory workers on the floor but
rather in the manager right so already
there there's a kind of notion of
there's already a kind of relation of
production that produces a kind of
notion of what counts as intelligence
and it's gathering together if a call
activity into kind of the category
mistake of the individual I just want to
quickly to point of irrational and
authorship and corporation I think on
another institution project directive
that's at the table and in the room the
the sort of collective scientist and the
collection of facts that science
produces and the notion of authorship in
that realm I think is really interesting
I think in my experience there's almost
an opposing um problem which is that in
my experience the art world art rarely
exists without an author in my
experience of science and scientific
discussions about how memory does or
doesn't work we're not split or state
there doesn't state facts are split from
their producers and I think this is
interesting to Professor Jones's point
in terms of power in code also the
notion of math or software as neutral
and without author and then in the
science world the notion of facts as
without author and what that produces
and and and why that comforts us I think
it eliminates subjects and the
petitions of specific cohorts of
subjects it eliminates the scientist as
subjective it eliminates the study of
myself as study of other which i think
is comforting as a construction of
objectivity in a way to study ourselves
or no results actually but I think um in
the same way there's an interesting
psychology of the artist as always offer
or science as without author a sort of
ex nihilo science there's interesting
psychology to why I think it's
comforting to consider myself to
ourselves or intelligence as a
collective in that it lets you
understand and not understand at once
and that's okay where you can say we can
boil down to parts and I can see the
parts and so I'm a materialist scientist
and that is comforting but at the same
time there's a sort of week at the
phenomenalism where you can say those
parts construct a mystery and that
leaves some space for free will or soul
or whatever you'd like to put in there
um so I think that psychologists all of
these are really interesting that this
psychology of giving personhood to
corporation a psychology of giving
perhaps too much personhood to an art
project or perhaps the personhood out of
a scientific project well I think we
should break the hermetic seal and I'm
the five of us and see if there's some
questions from our audience I've been so
kind to well be voting them up and down
over here
your questions up let's let's yes that's
a good question we one of the one of the
one of the things that I was wondering
is if intelligence and creativity would
be considered distinctly as some people
in for instance and computational
creativity like to think of creativity
as being distinct from artificial
intelligence the way that
problem-solving behavior is treated
there so I mean yes this perspective was
was not was that they what's what's
intelligence I meant I'm gonna defer to
the ethnographer I'm interested in
actors categories so my main question
would the slime mold is what is this
thing that you mean when you say the
word intelligence so mostly I want to
ask that question not answer it
right so I think that you know the
emerging ideas of art and culture that I
see us celebrating in some way as some
Demming Hemi semi collective up here is
to question the computational
motherboard as the metaphor for
intelligence right the Babbage manager
the man behind the curtain
the you know homo ratio not took so
whatever Lina called it right the kind
of gubernatorial heading steers you
right to kind of question it and to say
that it's time to acknowledge that other
things are happening things that seem to
have purpose
and form and and seem to push things
into being that are not necessarily
driven by some rational intelligence at
the center so do we want to abandon the
word or do we want to retool it that's
kind of the project that's the question
at hand I'm not sure which is it's
fatally compromised it certainly has its
sociological and racist baggage so maybe
we yeah but again there's a market there
as well right when I wanted to get some
digitized images for teaching I got
nowhere with a library they didn't have
any money but when I called it an is MTD
problem when a common an information
management problem suddenly I had all
these people saying we'll write some
software for that right so they thought
they could sell an intelligent system in
digital like they kind of forgot
PowerPoint existed but they thought they
could sell an intelligent teaching
platform the library didn't have
think to self it just had all this
collective memory and mighty gets it a
budget you know so this is you know
there's also a market and intelligence
so I think that I think for one thing
that definition is contextually
suggested so in many ways MIT what
intelligence is is a sort of back
formation from artificial intelligence
government which were military guidance
systems political intelligence was an
MIT it's also a techno scientific
category that's the tool with which
that's the discipline or which to
approach it right right rather than
intelligent design rather than make the
tools that a particular religious
cosmology that's why I'm trying to push
this the conversation and with my work
my questions that I'm asking myself as
far away from any
anthropomorphize ation or human
associated but also machining new to
other reals into alien intelligence and
to into microbial intelligence into
non-organic
intelligence like intelligence of
particles because I think that one of
the problems is that we associated all
this and I think a lot of these notions
were exactly created kind of on the
basis of certain cliches that that
emerged various fields and we have to
take it somewhere and for me and one
we're like the intelligence I could but
really something is is the unknown you
know like this of the the the something
that is I'm looking for it and unknown
irrational otherworldly and because
other all this other categories we've
kind of I feel like hit the wall I may
be oh I was I was gonna see if we could
there was one in back yes
I'm so it's a question as to whether we
have new discoveries on slime molds
which I must admit I do not like I'm you
asked of me may be able solving a maze
most recently I mean what was
establishment on this final is that it
has a memory it's capable of
collectively memorizing the show kind of
also refers to the question of
intelligence because of course like you
know remembering and learning it has a
capability of learning even though it
doesn't have a nervous system so it's in
a way similar to in their world network
that it's that it's somehow learns and I
have a book to recommend which is
there's a professor at Princeton who has
spent his life with these organisms kind
of along the model of the wonderful
Japanese researcher who presented them
to the emperor in 1930 as the model of a
good Society anyway the guy husband's
last name is Bonner
and the book is just called the social
amoeba and it's beautifully illustrated
it's small it's lovely to read and he
and he talks about all the things that
are known and the much larger things
that aren't never about how this
creature organizes and you know it's in
the family of funghi right we don't know
much about funny
they are everywhere and they are the
plants are down here in evolutionary
line you know animals are here in the
evolution line and up there there they
act collaboratively they provide
communication channels for other
symbiotic creatures that they're in long
run for plant you know trees and I mean
so like stay tuned
the funny you know are giving us a lot
of the chemical signaling that is just
beginning to be seen as intelligent I
want to ask though about the idea that
for repetition of previous states and
shapes that we call this memory I mean
we all you could also have a memory foam
pillow and we wouldn't attribute it with
the intelligence in fact the fact that
our computers have memory is not the way
the Babbage of course talked to them he
talked to not the processor in memory
but the neural in the store right so he
had the industrial metaphor for
computing and our computer would be
spoken out much more like ended up in
these factory terms except for the fact
that because later reframed as a giant
brain but we have gigabytes of storage
said this is no order no only a metaphor
but I'm saying that we often project
into into these concepts metaphorically
and it's and so nothing not that slime
molds are interesting I'm not trying to
assert that that's proudly but but I
think we should also be thinking about
what we are incredibly discussing and
what we're projecting on and then by the
name social what does that mean I mean
does that make any sense
yeah yes yeah
elected cousins for this act of
producing something collectively there's
like profit sharing and credit sharing
and I think along those lines with after
like thinking about the cases of acting
what's in it for the termite yeah yes
well you know that actually I have to
say honestly I consciously used the
termites as a model of salt of soft
exploitation because the termites think
that you know it's this kind of like
interesting phenomena then they are
almost blind they don't see what they
are building out of for example they
don't see that these are just crazy
colors instead of like the gray or
orange black mud and it was just like a
brilliant for me interesting people to
talk about soft exploitation it's like
how our day guys exploited or like you
know how I have to point out they
weren't even invited to the opening you
know a question that I'm being asked
very often
okay so you're talking about this
collective intelligence and a collective
also should by then the end of the day
you're just like a single author and you
know one of the things that interests me
I I think that this questions of also
singular authorship we're really
witnessing some sort of erosion of the
singular author but it's not that we're
already I don't really know this is one
of my areas of inquiry where is it going
to go I just know that individual
authorship is kind of you know eroding
and we can see it already in science we
can see it a knowledge production in
individual arts as pointed out it they
will be the last to go absolutely I
couldn't agree more but you know for
example when you look at science how
novel price used to be just given to a
single person more recently there is
there is a kind of uptick there because
more recently not only is given two
groups of people sometimes a team of
three to three to four scientists but
also more interestingly is given to nooh
tendency to two or three people who
discovered the same thing in different
parts of the world and I think that this
is an interesting development that you
know may need to something else and also
in the field of culture but we may wait
for it we may not be witnessing this I
just think that something is changing
and I'm happy to be witnessing this but
where it's gonna go I don't know
yeah and I might just add that if you
want to see the models of profit on the
animal kingdoms and the fungal kingdoms
I mean you know Brewers East was the
first animal to become the first fungi
to be sequenced is the origin of the
word biotechnology the bruises so we've
been kind of exploiting you know these
branches for a long long time
what's interesting is that humans
reflect on these practices so humans are
saying well it was fun to have a couple
of pigs but 7000 in a windowless
container is that fun so you know in my
own work I'm interested in these modes
of visible evasion and the fact that we
create architectures with no windows
because some part of our culture is
nervous that the question what's in it
for the pigs is going to come up right
when we're just you know we've
engineered them to have six months
lifespans where they triple in size on
particular kinds of feed you know I mean
we're producing them as machines to feed
us and so the question of ethics of
these relationships you know it's being
addressed but in very personalized ways
that fit with neoliberalism did you eat
a hamburger today right rather than what
is our collective responsibility to this
planet into the life forms should we
always maximize human life I mean is
that our ethical organization so these
questions of the collective are still
pressing and make me want to cry because
we need to have these conversations all
the time we need to so I really value
your question well I do as well
Caroline I think that one of the things
about it is that it also brings the
question down to the specifics of how do
we collaborate not not how do we solve
every global problem related to
industrial agriculture but how is it
that
own practices could be fair to
crowdsource labor that we employ but how
do we think about this in relationship
to machine to other sort of machine
animal you know unusual collaborations
but how do we situate that and what we
might do as people working in art
science or as as others thinking about
those types of collaborations yes
so the kind of horrible perversion
I distributed automata do you have an
idea I'm pretty excited that the in
terms of the power of reframing these
different metaphors for work Penny's
different metaphors for intelligence and
how that lets you reframe the person to
ask the questions I'm super excited
about about fungal networks
and mushrooms I would like probably go
ask I know he'd come across Paul Stamets
but he lectures on mushrooms while
wearing the mushroom as a hat and is an
inspiring creature
yeah I would probably knock on his door
and ask what he means by intelligence
some assert of intelligence which makes
up the world's largest and the world's
former oldest organism and which forms a
sort of intelligence that creates a
forest over hundreds of years
I think offers a lot of challenges to
that sort of a single author versus
collective forest question it offers a
lot of challenges to the short-term
profit versus long-term world question
so what you're asking about
kinds of trainings in language right so
people do use the word quickly I mean
maybe there would be a way to name it
that I'm how exploited that it is right
so somebody's working for IBM and
they're bored so they go over here and
make a dollar I mean you know is it
terribly exploitative
I mean it's far worse how Apple is
polishing its cases and you know toxic
chemicals so maybe there's a name for it
that would rivet maybe we would call it
like distracted cognitive capital
something like that you know what Joseph
Weizenbaum would say about this yeah
that bringing human activity and
computational trends and putting this
type of essentially stuffing people into
the that that's the it's not so much
that it's not the reference to Turkey
that's the problem there it's it's
actually a deeper problem of how the how
the project is formulated right now
we're using people to do some tasks that
happen to be hard for computers to do as
soon as we get that figured out and so I
do want to point out that then the giant
conversation could be yeah what about
the three-day workweek yeah what about
the what about the you know everybody
gets the same wage you know what I mean
there's so many conversations that we
could be having in this universe instead
of we're replacing all the truck drivers
I mean we have such an impoverished
imaginary around how to have this
conversation it's as though we in our
well I'm coming back to Adams metaphor
again and you know culture is this de
positive memory I mean we've just
forgotten the other part of the
collective conversation which is the
social collective that tries to make
things better for everybody in general
not for you know a few people in
particular so I mean that's we've just
kind of forgotten that whole
conversation well for me for example
what I call just like the dispersed
factory I mean in a way you know it's
like I think marks worst dream because
because it's a hundred percent
alienation because everybody's working
in front of their computer screen and
the possibilities of you know like a
unionization exist but are not as easy
as people interacting physically and of
course social media plays some role in
it but I think you know one of the
aspects the topic that interests me is
the flows of social energies and how
this changes with accelerations from
circulation of content and means that
every single with social media and and
and how much we still need the physical
bodies and physical interactions between
people and obviously questions about
this this new working class that is
emerging in front of our eyes right now
raises questions of what are we going to
have an equivalent of the
solution of against dis and against the
exploitation in this new emerging the
working class and and whether you know
the new platforms such as social media
will allow for an accelerated process to
for people to I don't know unionized or
do something else
in order to make the world better back
the rate this working conditions better
and a flip the bullets a lot are or not
and another point that I wanted to also
answer to what has been and saying about
the questions of like how can social
would make things better you know it's
through collective intelligence the
reason why I'm in my work implying this
idea of collective tamagotchi that I
that I was thinking a lot about is that
you know I realized that that there were
about I think 76 millions of tamagotchi
so you know this toys in a shape
actually toys sold worldwide 76 76
million but what if actually what could
imagine that all those people that both
this time ago just will just take her on
just one Tamagotchi and we have this our
rajasah planet Eric's basically there is
also an egg-shaped you know that we can
take care of and obviously people are
self-organizing in various ways to take
care of this collective Tamagotchi and
and this is a process of collective
intelligence South organization it's an
emergent process not everything is just
top-down organized by politicians and
governments but there are things and
maybe to answer your earlier question
about is there anything positive any way
to kind of you know work
coming probably to life towards an
answer this conversation there may be is
something positive is that so many
people around the world are involving in
self-organizing into this debate about
climate change which well and that's
obviously one of the many topics that
Caroline mentioned that we have to
discuss as well as things more directly
rising from the conversation we've had
so I think we should move to informal
conversation at this point food thanks
to those and thanks to
[Applause]
you